- Uhh, ooh, I've never
seen this guy in my life.
- (Host) Wanna show the camera?
- Yes
(piano music)
- So today we're gonna be
walking through Union Square,
giving people surprise
fourth grade quizzes
to see if they're smarter
than a fourth grader.
- (laughs) Umm, that's good.
- I might embarrass
myself but I'm still down.
- (laughs) Welcome to New York.
- That studies space but stays on Earth?
Astronomist.
- A scientist?
Is it a trick question?
- Definitely not scientology.
- An astrologist.
- [Host] Final answer?
- Final answer.
- Astronomer?
- [Host] Hey, good job!
- Really?
Okay.
- Astronomy, astronomers?
Yeah.
- [Host] Yeah, it's astronomers.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 365.
- To completely orbit the sun?
One day?
- 365.
- [Host] Correct.
- 366.
- One day.
- [Host] One?
Locking it in?
- I'm locking it in.
- [Host] All right, that's wrong.
- I guess I didn't pay
attention in middle,
in elementary school, I don't know.
- (Bleep) That was my first answer.
- He's handsome.
- That is our Vice President.
- That's Mike Pence, the Vice President
of the United States.
- I wanna say yeah,
his first name is Mike.
- Uh, it begins with a P.
- Um, no, I don't know who that is.
Who is it?
- Uh, I think he's part of military.
- I mean I know he's like in
the government at some point,
but like I don't know who that is.
- Uh, Mike Pence.
Yeah?
- [Host] Yes!
- Uh, yeah, I'm not too sure (laughs).
- Is this our Vice President?
This is probably Pence.
- [Host] That is Mike Pence.
- Ha ha!
- Uh, liberation, right?
- Does it have anything to do with health?
- Susan B. Anthony do
to ... I have no idea,
but I'll make a guess.
- Susan B. Anthony, I
have no clue what she did
to help other women.
- To get the vote.
- [Host] Right.
- Uh, with slavery, I don't remember.
- It's the right to vote.
- Uh, like voting rights.
- Suffrage rights, yeah?
Women's suffrage.
- [Host] Correct, women's suffrage.
- Jay-Z.
- Jay-Z, it's all over the place.
- So the real question is: Can
you write Jay-Z in cursive?
- I haven't done cursive
since like the sixth grade.
- Oh, a Z in cursive?
Jesus.
- (laughs)
- Why is that cheating?
It says Sean Carter.
(piano music)
- I did not do well. (laughs)
- I was relieved that it
was fourth grade questions.
- I think taking a fourth
grade test was refreshing.
- I've seen a bunch of videos online
where they take people
aside to ask these questions
and they give ridiculous answers,
so I just didn't want to be one of those.
An astrologist.
I think I am one of those
now, so, yeah. (laughs)
(piano music)